ja hallo hier sind glasperlenspiel
caroline und daniel und mein name ist
christoph krachten von pixum und wir
machen mit bei dem großen wettbewerb 361
grad respekt und da geht es gegen
mobbing für toleranz und ihr könnt
videos machen
denn mobbing ist richtig mies caroline
du hast erfahrung damit gemacht wie viel
scheiße ja klar also es auf jeden fall
so dass es sehr wichtig ist
mal sich dagegen aufzulehnen und anderen
zu helfen und sich da einzumischen und
deswegen macht euer video etwas cooles
zusammen auf habt spaß beim video drehen
und schickt euer video ein und dann
könnt ihr ein konzert von uns gewinnen
da sind mit hammer und vor allen dingen
mit einem song der zum thema passt ja
wir haben einen song geschrieben da
heißt lasst uns bewegen auf unserer
neuen platte auch drauf die dann
erscheinen wird mitte mai und man kann
gespannt sein also auf jeden fall macht
mitmacht oder video gegen mobbing für
mehr toleranz
wir würden uns freuen wenn wir dann bei
euch auftritt dürfen genau also haut
rein 360 61 grad der wettbewerb auf
youtube ihr könnt euren ideen freien
raum lassen
lasst euch was einfallen in diversen
kategorien solch kunst musik alles
mögliche und bis zum 17
geht es noch lasst euch also etwas
einfallen und wir sind gespannt auf eure
videos sancho bleibt dran